peuple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
planar 20h45 blessés un drame de 10
secondes ce n'est pas un tremblement de
terre qui a créé ce paysage des pointes
l'écroulement de quelques cavernes ou de
quelques galeries souterraines vestiges
des carrières de sont sortis des pierres
de paris a soudain fait craquer la
croûte de terre qui s'est affaissé de 5
à 6 mètres
un immeuble de trois étages 25 pavillons
une petite usine non plus été que des
des cons le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur roger frey est venu encourager
les équipes de secours qui avec un
acharnement de fourmi se sont efforcé
pendant trois jours de sauver ce qui
pouvait vivre encore sous cet
amoncellement de moellons de ciment et
de poutres
[Musique]
des blessés on en comptera en définitive
45 engloutie sous leurs murs des morts
on en comptera 20 enfouis dans cet
entonnoir soudainement creusé sur une
superficie de 6 hectares et au delà de
ces deuils brutaux il y à l'immense
tragédie des gens qui ont perdu un père
ou un enfant
le drame de ceux à qui il ne reste rien
de ce qui faisait leur vie quotidienne
spectacle dramatique spectacle affreux
on reste sans voix devant un désastre
aussi inattendu aussi inimaginable
[Musique]
versailles était le dernier des corps
est le dernier acte de la visite du
président des états unis à paris et à
travers cette admirable toile de fond on
a pu voir le général de gaulle et madame
kennedy ouvrir le cortège qui allaient
circonstances dont la rareté fait aussi
le prix dîner dans la galerie des glaces
ferment le cycle des entretiens de paris
cette brillante soirée était la préface
d'un autre cycle celui de vienne où
monsieur khrouchtchev et monsieur
kennedy s'était donné rendez vous un
premier entretien ce la seule à
l'ambassade américaine en précédait un
autre à l'ambassade soviétique
de ces conversations laborieuse il ne
sortirait qu'un geste de bonne volonté
et une espérance c'est déjà quelque
chose car la soirée de schönbrunn qui
terminait ces deux journées et où les
deux cas routes chauffées kennedy
étaient les hôtes du président enchères
se terminaient un sourire de part et
d'autre on le sait la diplomatie n'en
est pas avare
mais c'est dans ce sourire de
khrouchtchev à madame kennedy ce sourire
de kennedy à madame coach of qu'on peut
peut être mieux que dans les communiqués
lire un peu l'espérance du monde et deux
tiers de la population du globe souffre
encore aujourd'hui de la faim ce thème
infligeant monsieur terrenoire ministre
de l'information la développer devant la
presse en donnant le départ d'une grande
collecte qui doit permettre à la france
d'apporter sa participation à la
campagne du mondial contre la faim
au palais de justice de paris le rideau
est tombé sur le procès au lourd dossier
de 2 des responsables du putsch d'alger
les juges du tribunal militaire nord ont
siégé que trois jours pour rendre leur
jugement après avoir entendu le
procureur besson leur dire
après des semaines de réflexion et de
drames de conscience je ne me sens pas
le droit de réclamer la peine de mort
[Musique]
quinze ans de réclusion c'est par cette
condamnation qui atteint maurice challe
et andré zeller que s'est terminé ce
procès exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au bourget le salon international de
l'aéronautique est arrivé à son terme
deux journées de parade aérienne à la
première de ces journées on a pu voir
s'envoler le bombardier américain b 58
qui reliait new york à paris en trois
heures 20 on ne devait hélas plus le
revoir
dans la campagne on n'a retrouvé que des
débris tout ce qui restait de l'appareil
et de son équipage ce drame qui garde
son mystère ne devait pas arrêter la
présentation on devait voir tour à tour
le singulier breguet 940 capable
d'atterrir en quelques mètres
un appareil moins exigeante encore le
short sc un britannique qui décolle et
atterrit à la verticale avec le gris
fameux place à aile delta les empennages
canard commencer la série des prototypes
français qui ambitionne les vitesses de
2500 km heure c'est ainsi qu'après le
mirage iii appareils d'intervention qui
équipe l'armée française et qui lui a
servi de modèle
on a pu voir le mirage quatre
biréacteurs premier bombardier atomique
européen
95 appareils les plus rapides les plus
gros ou les plus révolutionnaires ont
ainsi inscrit dans le ciel du bourget
les promesses de l'aviation
[Musique]
deux cent cinquante mille personnes de
générations de reine la reine elizabeth
et sa mère pour assister au derby
d'epsom qui consacre le meilleur cheval
de la saison entre chevaux au départ
pour 2400 mètres de course au bout
desquels se trouve une petite fortune
60 millions au vaincu de quoi donner le
vertige à tous et jockeys qui prennent
le départ tambour battant
beaucoup de chevaux français dans ce
peloton et parmi eux quelques favoris
enfonçant rangs serrés comme un
reichshoffen personne ne se détache tout
le monde veut gagner de fait chacun des
chevaux peut encore prétendre gagner
tous les favoris sont là et aussi à
cheval que personne n'attend psyllium
quelques coups de cravache de son choc
et roger poincelet pour 60 millions ça
en vaut la peine
epci diom coiffe tout le monde sur le
poteau la reine est déçu son favori et
bac pro taxi diom sépare des ruades
coquine qu'il manifeste sa joie avec
roger poincelet
il a joué un bon tour à tous les
parieurs
match de la dernière chance pour le
racing club de paris maillot clair
devant l'équipe du havre une dernière
chance que les joueurs parisiens ont
l'air de vouloir saisir du bout des
pieds
[Applaudissements]
ils mènent rapidement par 1 à 0 racing 1
racing qui n'aurait pas dû attendre la
dernière journée du championnat de
france pour essayer de décrocher le
titre de champions 2 0 les parisiens
sont bien partis ils sont champions de
france du moins momentanément
d'autant qu'à monaco les monégasques eux
sous le regard sévère de leur souverain
peine visiblement devant valenciennes
maillot français comme les monégasques
mais parements blancs sur la poitrine
monaco doit absolument gagner s'ils ne
veut pas laisser le titre de champion de
france au parisien et pour le moment il
n'en prend pas le chemin
et pourtant c'est un incident le jeu qui
va donner la victoire aux monégasques
fuck de valenciennes suivie d'un coup ça
[Applaudissements]
carrier ma pour monaco un but qui vaut
un titre de champion pendant ce temps au
havre le racing baisse les bras tous ses
espoirs se sont envolés les havrais en
profite ce sont eux qui s'amusent
maintenant et qui map successivement
deux bus qui leur donne un match nul
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe
à
si monaco c'est l'heure du triomphe pour
la première fois ils sont champions de
france
le rideau vient se baisser sur une
saison fertile en émotions
à ce pacifique lâcher de ballons succès
d'un spectacle qui l'est beaucoup moins
les trente trois monstres en flotte de
voitures qui participent aux 500 miles d
indianapolis sont lâches pour le moment
avec leurs 400 chevaux sous le capot
ils sont encore bien sam
pas pour longtemps ce serait 3
voilà le festival commence
[Musique]
inutile de vous déranger messieurs il
n'y a que des blessés légers
ça fait cependant cinq concurrents deux
mois sur le circuit où les rescapés
continuent de rouler à plus de 200
valent quand les monstres ne tourne pas
ce sont les mécanos qui bat des records
de vitesse en quelques secondes on vous
fait le plein et on vous change de 4 il
ne reste plus grand monde sur la piste à
la fin de l'épreuve 12 voitures
franchissent la ligne d'arrivée
ces fêtes qui terminent le premier qui
gagne les 50 millions du vainqueur ce
qui somme toute n'est peut-être patron
pour ce qu il a risqué
[Musique]